Move over, "Fat Thor" everybody's favorite
electric Asgardian just got a new, less fat-shamey
moniker.
In advance of the digital and Blu Ray release
of Avengers: Endgame, Marvel Studios released
an extensive list of the special features
awaiting home viewers and one of those features
is entitled "The Creation of Bro Thor," which
is a slightly more charitable nickname.
It's just the latest development in the ongoing
saga of… well, we suppose we're calling
him "Bro Thor" now, although we were always
partial to Tony Stark's christening of the
Thunder God as "Lebowski."
"Nobody calls me 'Lebowski.'
You've got the wrong guy.
I'm The Dude, man."
In case you somehow weren't aware of the uproar
over the character's portly new physique in
Endgame, allow us to recap the madness for
you.
In the film's first act, Thor out of sheer
rage and frustration unceremoniously decapitated
Thanos after the Avengers and Captain Marvel
tracked the Mad Titan down to his farm planet.
It turned out that Thanos had essentially
set the Infinity Stones to self-destruct after
using them to complete his mission of wiping
out half of all life in the universe.
Without the stones, the Avengers had no way
to undo what had been done.
The film then jumped forward five years, a
period during which our heroes had adjusted
to post-Decimation life in a variety of ways.
Natasha Romanoff desperately struggled to
keep all of Earth's defenders on the same
page in the hope of averting another catastrophe.
Bruce Banner found a way to retain his smarts
and personality after Hulking out.
"Eighteen months in the gamma lab.
I put the brains and the brawn together.
And now look at me.
Best of both worlds."
Tony Stark got married and had a precocious
daughter who loved him 3000.
As for Thor?
Uhh, well …
"I think I'm having a panic attack."
"Get it together!"
Well, Thor retired to the New Asgard settlement
in Norway to play Fortnite with Korg, drink
all of the beer he could possibly get his
hands on, and put on just a few pounds.
Recruited by Banner and Rocket to take part
in the Avengers' audacious plan to travel
back to various periods in time to secure
the Infinity Stones before Thanos could, Odinson
came along only half-willingly.
For a good portion of the film especially
during his encounter with his mother Frigga
during a jaunt back to Asgard in 2013 it was
obvious that his physical changes were a result
of a deep depression.
At a crucial moment, he had failed his friends
and the planet he had sworn to protect by
way of not going for Thanos' head, an oversight
which gave the Mad Titan the opportunity to
snap his big purple fingers and make the Avengers'
worst fear a reality.
"You should have gone for the head."
"NOOO—"
Now, we should mention that during Endgame,
a few tasteless jokes were lobbed Thor's way.
These jokes provoked the ire of a sizable
swath of the internet, as many felt that the
character was being fat-shamed, and that his
depression was used as a device to make him
the butt of simplistic gags.
Still others, though, read the situation a
bit differently.
Sure, Stark had a few snarky things to say
about Thor's round waistline; we submit that
this is because he was Tony Stark, and it
would've been completely out of character
for him to not lob a few zingers at his friend.
Further, Hemsworth gave an absolutely brilliant
performance which managed to hit comedic notes
while being a completely relatable illustration
of the realities of depression and don't even
get us started on the fact that, despite sinking
to his lowest point, he was still worthy of
wielding his beloved Mjolnir.
"Are you crying?"
"No!
…...Yes."
We're not crying you're crying!
Screenwriters Christopher Markus and Stephen
McFeely have even stated that it was their
intention to use Thor's fragile mental state
to humanize the Asgardian to a degree and
in our humble opinion, they pulled that off
smashingly.
Well, to no one's surprise, it seems that
Marvel Studios must have caught wind of the
whole brouhaha, and made the understandable
decision that the "fat" descriptor just wasn't
going to work for official purposes.
We think it's a laudable choice.
How will the ever-polarized internet respond?
All we can do is wait and find out.
Fortunately for Marvel Studios, they make
movies that are beloved by you, everybody
you know, everybody they know, and so on.
But even the MCU can't please everybody, and
we sincerely doubt that Marvel even feels
pressured to try at this point.
Renaming the stocky Asgardian "Bro Thor" was
a thoughtful move, and one that shows that
the House of Ideas isn't into shaming anybody.
Except, of course, for bros.
We can expect an overwhelming wave of indignation
from the online bro community at any moment.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.